comme des milliers de Montréal et Claude
Hamel doit filtrer son eau pour qu'elle
ne soit pas contaminée il y a du plan
dans l'eau c'est un vieux quartier avec
des infrastructures qui ont de l'âge
alors voilà on est bien content que ça
se passe Montréal sait qu'il y a du
plomb dans son eau depuis plus de 15 ans
en 2019 la ville s'était engagée à
accélérer les remplacements selon les
chiffres obtenus par Radio-Canada il
restera à la fin de l'année près de 50
000 entrées d'eau à changer depuis 2018
4000 changements ont été effectués en
moyenne par année l'échéancier initial
fixé à 2030 a déjà été repoussé à 2032
mais au rythme actuel ce serait plutôt
2034 c'est vraiment surprenant parce que
c'était l'enjeu de santé l'opposition
réclame d'abord plus de prévisibilité
pour les citoyens la ville va les
annoncer ah oui en fait ça dans deux
semaines tout le monde les gens papa
juste tirer l'argent d'une chapeau la
plupart de nous ont besoin de mettre un
peu d'argent à côté pour être capable
bien planifié parce que lorsque la ville
fait les travaux sur sa section publique
si la section privée est aussi en plomb
elle la remplace en même temps et
facture le propriétaire les risques liés
au plomb sont minimes pour la majorité
de la population selon la santé publique
de Montréal mais certaines personnes
sont plus à risque même à faible
concentration on parle de jeunes enfants
de femmes enceintes à cause des effets
possibles sur les jeunes enfants on peut
avoir des impacts au niveau du
développement langagier cognitif alors
vraiment les bases du développement de
l'enfant malgré la cadence de
remplacement insuffisante jusqu'à
maintenant la ville pense pouvoir
accélérer les travaux en est absolument
confiant terminé en 2032 pourquoi parce
que cette année seulement on a remplacé
4000 entrées de service d'eau alors
l'objectif pour les 10 prochaines années
c'est d'en faire 600 de plus alors c'est
réaliste on va atteindre l'objectif
20-32 Claude lui pourra se débarrasser
de son pichet dans les prochaines
semaines d'autres vont vivre avec encore
au moins une décennie ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal